hello there it's actually happened
fortnite sent us back to the Glory Days
of 2018 as the story of time travel
reaches its Crescendo today we are going
to look at the map changes from 5 years
ago and piece together the plan for Dr
Sloan who has sent Jones back to take a
very specific item back to the future
I'm Adam please drop a like for the
series to return and here we
go this version of the chapter 1 island
is set over over multiple Seasons from
the heroes and villain bases of season 4
all the way through to the memorial of
the destruction of tilted that led up to
season 9 this island is a mess of time
zones but as the weeks draw by almost
all the best bits of chapter 1 will be
seen again wait is
that it is we'll get back to that beauty
very soon over at Pleasant Park
something has crash landed on the field
once held by a balloon this device is
now broken it's the time machine from
our Heist against a vampire I'll link
last season's story if that made no
sense to you and you want to know more
about Sloan and that time traveling
device right now an accompanying message
from Sloan gives us a little more
context Jones slan here tomorrow you
take the time machine back everything
you do will Ripple forward to this very
moment Jones is here to take something
back to the future if you'd like the
item to be secret please fast forward to
this time now okay they gone good I
first thought we were here for a
smashing grab on Kevin the cube but
leakers have revealed the real Target
the rocket first used by the visitor in
chapter 1 season 4 to identify the
location of the zero point in loot Lake
and then reconstructed by the scientist
to potentially end the loop and find the
iio bridge this time keep your eyes on
the ruined Cafe at Dusty divot as it
will change over time as the rocket
arrives and is repurposed with a strapon
time machine in fact we've already seen
what could happen what's particularly
mindblowing is that that we may have
already been shown chapter 5's date on
winning our umbrella this season we have
two dates from the future Star Wars Day
2024 and June 8th
2068 could we be going to the latter in
chapter 5 this is getting a little LW
heavy right now so let's put a pin in
the story and look at some of the iconic
map updates and upcoming
changes over in the desert biome the
birthplace of Kevin the cube is already
active eight Scorch marks on the the
ground and if you remember back in
October 2018 a mysterious crack in the
sky obliterated a group of cactuses to
make room for Kevin's arrival the most
surprising thing back then was the mini
event happened without any notice in
game millions of people totally missed
out and epic being epic they timed it
perfectly for Ninja to witness the birth
of the
cube bro is this is this an
event
what just happened
back now in 2023 we know that manyi live
events will be here again this season
but it's unclear what date and time
Kevin will take his return but when he
does and he starts rolling again I fear
for one place in particular the most
important fortnite update in
history hot watch this my friends is the
original hot watch the moment this thing
was destroyed we watched it rebuild over
Seasons upon Seasons until it was ripped
from our grasp when we all fell into a
black hole the Hut refused used to be
beaten and reassembled itself in Chapter
2 after a freak collision with a hall
truck if this is the original hot watch
then Kevin the cube is coming this way
very soon and there's another Kevin
related update up in tilted Towers the
no sweat Insurance building stands
proudly this is not canonically right
for the season we're set in as the
memorial diarama inside is an Ode to the
rocket event the rolling Cube and even
the volcano event too and as we can see
there is no volcano here yet watch this
space going back to 2018 gives us a new
perspective on Old theories up in
wailing Woods be sure to stop at the
hatch originally this was an Easter egg
reference to the TV show Lost and their
Island's mysterious bunker but fortnite
evolved and many years later we had our
Theory confirmed that this is actually
how IO get above ground when we're not
looking it took Batman to give us that
law from a comic book then at the end of
chapter 2 we saw it for ourselves the
two members of the seven who visited the
OG Island knew exactly how to break into
the layer underneath sadly our bunker in
game right now leads well nowhere but
it's amazing to think back 5 years when
we were all wondering what could this be
for to my surprise the original Easter
egg from fortnite season zero is in game
right now get your butt over to the
containers these containers hold many
Secrets but one is more important than
the rest hidden impossible to reach
inside is this back in 2018 I had no
idea what this was and in 2023 I still
have no idea what this is this thing is
a luggage bag with a miniaturized
cabbage conveyor belt if anyone at all
Can Shed light on this what does it mean
I'm begging for answers fortnite has an
ongoing Memorial Easter egg when players
do something incredibly funny which
usually causes their downfall we've seen
players yeeting themselves across
Islands we've seen glitches through the
world but the OG memorial for chapad
dooodle and his wood beavor muselk is in
game right now off to the right of
Paradise Palms by The wat's Edge is this
gravestone muselk made a vant effort to
save another player who was stuck below
the build limit and ended up making the
situation worse epic then decided to
honor the duo with a gravestone so come
down here to pay your respects oh and
don't you worry if you're here in no
builds because each of the lower Ledges
in game now has a free Rift to use to
escape and Loki this method of getting
around the island is overpowered but it
does come at the risk of dropping into
the ocean this is chapter 1 we cannot
swim another OG Easter egg has also come
back take a look see at the milk cartons
in the world and do they ring a bell
this design was taken from a music video
from Brit pop band blur and their coffee
and TV music video in which a carton
tries to find a missing person it then
falls in love and well it gets a bit
harrowing a few seasons later all milk
cartons in fortnite were switched out to
boring red ones but now it's great to
see the OG ones are here once again and
there's more OG secrets to relive we all
know that dancing by a mounted fish on a
wall results in them boogying back well
over in retail row try this in front of
the giant fish sign for epicness totally
works but sadly the one that tilted does
not work rip a decent side mission in
week one for fortnite OG sees us finding
and collecting 10 versions of a gnome
this dude is gram and it looks like we
are seeing a precursor to the Gomes
versus teddy bears story from chapter 2
basically a the war broke out between
the two factions before then signing a
ceasefire and the Gnomes left the island
forever in this version of events most
of the gnomes are coexisting completely
fine with their teddy bear friends but
one is in danger back at wailing Woods
this guy is imprisoned was this the
event which started the war in Chapter 2
surprisingly there's an artifact from
chapter 4 here also one of the Bears is
reading Sloan's notes about objects of
power this one relates to the queen of
gold Aurelia hopefully it's just a
coincidence or maybe this ridiculous
storyline is
returning when we all logged into
fortnite for the first day back in time
we could see Ninja's OG load out this
includes his bespoke pickaxe if you were
here in 2018 you'd remember how this
happened ninja was desperate for
something in game to spend money on and
joked that he would buy a toilet plunger
as a pickaxe epic heard these cries and
combined his Katana with a toilet
plunger and the rest is history y it's
iconic I'll leave you with a question
one of the Gnomes can be found to the
right of Paradise Palms looking at two
gravestones one of which has a picture
can anyone identify this character
please let me know in the comments thank
you very much each week fortnite's map
will update like the days of old leading
to another end event will it be another
black hole will it be a rift in the sky
will it relate to the rocket from the
villains Lair fortnite OG is going to
change the story forever and I can't
wait to see what happens it's only here
for a month so enjoy every second you
can I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see you
next
time